wie ich das bei der us general
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
auf eurem lieblings kanal von hinten
über die zuschauer max und ich haben uns
mal wieder beisammen versammelt bei max
ein geisteskranker spieler aus nehmen
die mich nochmal vorgehen von den spielt
dieses zur spritze das erfolgreiche
video auf meinen kanal das haben wir
damals zusammen gespielt ist schon lange
her
bei uns sagt er sätze hätten das stimmt
man muss dazu sagen das video hat
mehrere video preise abgestaubt damals
also sehen wir noch mal hier der trina
eingeblendet
vor allem da kann ich dir leider nicht
weiterhelfen
es gibt auf jeden fall ein neues spiel
von den machern von die weltspitze
das spiel heißt ganz so happy party
party es gibt auf jeden fall das heißt
mit nachwuchs unter vista porträtist um
dieses ding und es kann hat man also du
meinst es kann ja was kann auch noch
kann es auch dass das kind ist es gibt
auf jeden fall zwei verschiedene modi
bis fuß und zwar das ganze schon sogar
testmodus er kann einfach drauf und dann
kurz das ding hat allerdings nach diesem
modus und dann auch dass dinge nämlich
dass hier immer mehr braucht wird immer
höher und nebenmann
nicht besser geht leider in die luft und
wenn das passiert müssen wir ein
ekelhaftes getränken ein glas film da
kommt allerdings gleich zu den ersten
schon wieder an die nächste punkt
angetreten wird auf websites also
wenigsten fehler karte habe musste ich
vier mal drücken
aber wenn ich dann kommst du nicht raus
ja ich glaube wir haben schon begriffen
worum es hier geht also die haben jetzt
sieben taten bei den karten gibt es
verschiedene zahlenwerte also von 1 bis
zu hier allerdings gibt es auch einige
da muss man nämlich an nicht drücken des
völkern punktion ihren reden den
jüngeren zeit nutzen wie kommt man gar
nicht an
natürlich wenn ich hier ein drama mich
[Musik]
wieder besser
auf jeden fall haben wir jetzt den
kartenstapel in der mitte und wir werden
das natürlich nicht normal war drin von
wegen wir drücken und dadurch raus weil
damit das spiel ja auch nicht gemacht
und das video würde nicht über zehn
minuten gehen bevor max und ich dann
noch weiter dumme heißen brei umlagern
erkläre ich euch einfach mal hier ganz
kurz die challenge und zwar befüllen wir
fünf gläser mit einer seite ekelhaften
flüssigkeiten allerdings auch mit ganz
normalen substanzen beispielsweise
wasser und immer derart kurz muss eins
dieser gläser blind nehmen und trinken
wippe film z
schön dass ich in meinen mund nehmen wir
eine tomate waschen legen
freuen dann auf den boden
ich und mache da nicht verbringt
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die nachricht sein oben im
video
bald steht da jetzt für die dritte haben
wir etwas kraft überlebt haben ihre
freundin alles überlegt dass wir auch
noch das wasser rein machen
[Musik]
die schmeckt kennt mit wasser und
gehörten tomate wir haben halt selbst
sagt er jetzt noch eine welt die wir
hier einfach du bist uns ja einmal als
3235 der das ding ist jetzt willkommen
glauben wirklich glauben bisschen gehen
sie war deine nächste karte erst mal
angehen er schon einige harte gott und
ich sah keine viele etwas völlig was
bringt - bringt mitbringen gibt es nicht
ja es war die richtige augen auf
[Musik]
burke mit wasser
das ist so abgesetzt schon richtig also
schmeckt die ich nur noch gewürzgurke
einfach ist gebrochen ist nichts was
hätte jemand danach gefragt
allerdings würde ich sagen da nicht
verloren habe da habe ich jetzt auch
anfang anfang ein kreuz ich muss nicht
max nächste karte
es ist eine vier leute zum anfang ist
das noch in ordnung
wir als die max abitur schnee
weil die nächste karte ist eine 22
glaube ich später noch schaffen
sehr gut das würdigen ist gegenstand
eines in der stadt wird sondern 450 bist
du dran
die engagierte die brief und ich hoffe
aber dass ich hoffe ja dass hofft das
wasser welches gewürzgurken denkt der
ethikrat und marco fritz und max hat
eine ich muss dich nix könnte ich dachte
ich glaube auch für junge der misch
meister wieder am werk gewesen hier auch
nix hey das ist ja gerade dieser spanne
und her dass wir elfmeter verschießen
damit für 3,1 hier musiker durch die wir
begleitet existent
nein nein ich glaube ich glaube zwei
stück schafft der doccheck gewicht bei
notfällen oder verwandten
welche rechte hat
wie bewertest der sache aller zeit okay
da du ja ist verpackt hast du dich sagen
dafür ist auch wieder starten diese
regel war da ich absolut gar keinen sinn
aber ein einzelner hinten langsam los
mit mister pups ich habe mir aber
komplett kaputt gespart auch eine eins
wieder sehr ordentlich gemischt was ich
sein
eine fähe hier ist zwar noch nicht so
dass ich glaube wenn ich jetzt eine 14
dann passiert nichts sehr gut ich glaube
alles was du bist dran
ich glaube es ist nicht wahr
etwas spannender hier ja xd aber dann
wird okay auch lena wir waren wieder
gemischt hat super dicke linkshänder
bestritt das ist eine 35 36
um ein lot der galaxis kraft das damit
hätte ich nicht gerechnet
ja eine 5 corning rein da aber noch eins
habe ich schon sehr bald 28 ok sichere
tipps was längst ist auch wasser ist
hier jemand gezweifelt
es schmeckt besser als burge würzburg
ich habe verloren und ich verrate
nächste runde geht aber wir sind relativ
tiefen noch im toren 1 wo das thema 38
jetzt bin ich dran aber das ist so
ziemlich das jetzt muss ich wasser oder
anträgen hilfe gaga jetzt ist mir heilig
wilde zahl würde
nein ich will jetzt um 19 uhr in god
eater so hoch war es noch kein bisschen
x3 herbekommen
[Applaus]
1 gefallen dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch und haben einen kanal noch nicht
abonniert haben schon immer in kanada
klickt auf die glocke da verpasst ihr
keine videos nicht auf jeden fall kommt
die tage bei max tatsächlich neu video
online wo wir einen burger google sind
ein bürger machen und welche mengen
davon überzeugen dass der superheld und
wenn ihr das sehen wollen dann da geht
doch aufmachen kanal vorbei ist und in
der beschreibung verlinkt machen was die
leute sitzen wörter als 1 719 erster
platz für bis zu 16 17